we have noses to smell eyes to see and
ears to hear right well actually your
ears are responsible for much more than
just hearing in fact they can even help
you taste and that's all thanks to
what's inside we think of ears as these
flappy appendages that stick out of our
heads but the most important structures
are actually on the inside and they're
known as the inner and middle ear inside
your middle ear is the nerve that moves
the muscles of your face aka the facial
nerve and if it becomes inflamed or
injured say from a nasty ear infection
you can lose control of the muscles in
your face but it could actually get
worse now along that facial nerve there
is a taste nerve it's called chorda
tympani that's right the nerve for taste
runs right through your middle ear and
if that nerve gets damaged you could
alter or even lose your sense of taste
permanently by the way not only are your
ears incredibly important for tasting
food but what you're listening to can
also change your foods flavor for
example research has shown that white
noise condole saltiness but enhance
crunchiness and in one study volunteers
perceived a dish to be a year when they
listen to the sound of clucking chickens
but whether it's the sound of chickens
or my beautiful voice it all enters your
ear through the cochlea a shell like
structure in the inner ear inside the
cochlea there are over 16,000 hairlike
cells which take vibrations entering
your ear and convert them into nerve
impulses those impulses travel to your
brain which turns them into the sound
you hear so if it weren't for those
cells you'd be deaf which is why it's
incredibly important that you keep them
protected especially from menaces like
bacteria viruses and even adventurous
insects and for that your ears best
defense is earwax
earwax is good it is not bad to have
your wax that's right
you need that gross golden wax it not
only has antibacterial properties but
it's also downright sticky helping to
stop invaders right in their tracks but
earwax isn't the only part of your inner
ear that keeps you healthy so there is a
tube made of muscle that connects the
back of your nose and your ears it's
called the you stay Keon tube and it
helps equalize pressure between your
ears and the atmosphere around you
normally the tube is sealed off so
nothing can travel between your ears and
your throat which keeps infections at
bay but when there's a change in
pressure like when you're taking off in
an airplane the air inside the tube
expands which typically makes you want
to pop your ears and that's a good thing
too because popping your ears opens the
tube and releases the air balancing the
pressure inside and out
speaking of balance there's one other
incredibly important structure you can
find inside your inner ear the
vestibular system kind of like a level
it controls your balance using a number
of liquid filled canals those balance
canals are responsible for telling your
body you are moving whether it may be
moving left to right or your body's
moving up and down as you move around
fluid in the canals sloshes against
millions of hairlike structures called
stereocilia and this sends a signal to
the brain where you process it as
movement that's why infections like the
common cold can sometimes make you feel
dizzy they often cause inflammation in
the vestibular nerve which distorts
those signals so the next time you find
yourself walking without falling over or
tasting your food or listening to well
anything think of your ears which as it
turns out have a lot more going on
inside than out